do you hear that that high-pitched buzz
did the sound of the future the future
of business according to just about
everyone here at the two-day drone world
expo in the heart of Silicon Valley
there are big drones and little drones
drones the do flips and groans the do
actual work like mapping mining sites
and monitoring agriculture check out
this drone called a flex rotor it can
take off like a helicopter and hit it in
midair to fly like a plane it's great
for surveillance and it costs two
hundred thousand dollars but a that's
cheap done a Gulfstream exhibitors put
drones and cages of mesh dancing them
around after all everyone loves drones
but no one wants a rotor in the eye
folks here are positively giddy in no
small part because the drone industry is
worth billions of dollars specifically
five billion in 2013 that's expected to
soar to almost 12 billion in 2023 more
and more hobbyists are taking to the sky
a drone racing league is watching next
year and amazon has plans to use drones
to deliver packages which may or may not
be a totally ridiculous
it's no wonder then that the FAA has
been struggling with a question of drone
regulation there are rules already in
place but recently a task force of
private companies sent the FAA their
recommendations we're forming these
regulations yeah it's all kind of a mess
but fear not drone numbers Joan lawyers
are already buzzing